[Musique]
le 4 janvier on est arrivé à tunis en
passant par paris le 5 janvier en après
midi on a pu dans les jours suivants
aller au centre du pays dans une région
qui s'appelle qu'erwan est la plus
pauvre du pays
et puis on a circulé beaucoup dans la
grande région de tunis pour réaliser les
reportages prévu dans ce voyage
alors on est venus pour produire un
grand reportage dans lequel y aura deux
grandes thématiques pour illustrer le
chemin parcouru au cours des dix
dernières années
depuis donc la révolution qui a mené au
départ du président ben ali il ya dix
ans en janvier 2011 d'abord l'économie
est-ce que les la situation des gens
s'est améliorée parce qu'au fond c'était
la revendication principale c'était la
pauvreté qu'on voulait combattre
et puis il y avait par ailleurs bien sûr
toute cette dimension de la liberté
d'expression retrouver puisque on
sortait d'une dictature où la liberté
d'expression n'existait pas on aura
aussi un autre reportage qui va parler
des relents d'islamisme de terrorisme
qui existe toujours dans ce pays
musulman qui a ses frontières d'un côté
l'algérie et la libye de l'autre à des
poches de résistance qui commettent
parfois encore aujourd'hui des attentats
dans le pays
[Musique]
au coeur de ce voyage y avait donc
l'objectif de rencontrer des gens qui
sont affectés par la crise économique et
on s'est rendus donc nord une région qui
est touché en particulier par un taux de
suicide anormalement élevé qui est lié à
la pauvreté ce qui nous a permis de
rencontrer un certain moment une dame
une veuve qui avait perdu son mari parce
qu'il lui avait été exclu d'un entente
gouvernementale avec les syndicats cette
dame diop a trouvé son mari à la porte
de la maison qui s'était immolé nous
racontait que ses enfants avaient vu
leur père mourir devant eux
donc cette dame qui nous racontait tout
ça pour faire comprendre à quel point la
situation économique et à tracer
elle nous a vraiment beaucoup touché les
membres de l'équipe et moi
la principal défi qu'on a ici pour cette
couverture c'est bien sûr de se déplacer
dans un pays qui est affecté comme le
reste de la planète par l'aco vim
l'autre c'est sans doute le fait qu' on
est encore dans un pays qui malgré les
dix ans de la révolution est encore dans
un esprit de contrôle policier
ce qui fait que on a des autorisations
qui nous permettent bien sûr de faire
tous les tournages à l'extérieur mais
qu'on est très très souvent obligé de
montrer nos papiers de se soumettre à
des contrôles d'attendre que les
vérifications soient faites avant de
pouvoir procéder à nos tournage à nos
entrevues dans des lieux publics
et j'ajoute que dans un voyage comme
celui ci surtout dans un pays arabe où
on maîtrise pas la langue du tout et on
maîtrise pas nécessairement la culture
ou les habitudes de vie le travail de
notre aide fixeur est fondamental dans
ce cas si mon ami walid que je connais
depuis des années a fait toute la
différence dans la possibilité de
rencontrer les gens comme faire des
traductions dans certains cas est de
permettre de voyager à travers le pays
[Musique]